It
was a weak ground ball to third base that
ended over a century’s worth of baseball
futility.
On November 3, 2016, the Chicago Cubs won
their first World Series in 108 years.
Much like the Red Sox win in 2004 that also
put the brakes on a similar streak, it propelled
the Cubs into another stratosphere in terms
of popularity.
The following April, according to the Los
Angeles Times, four of the top five player
jersey sales were Cubs.
Players appeared on talk shows and late night
comedy sketches.
Even the backup catcher had his moment in
the sun, with a second-place finish on Dancing
with the Stars.
Despite this popularity, many people don’t
know why the Chicago Cubs are named after
a baby bear.
After all, there are no longer any wild bears
in Illinois.
Here’s the story of how they got that name
and the sad story of their real life bear
mascots who used to join them in the dugout.
Cap_ansonIn February of 1876, Chicago businessman
William Hulbert (known for grocery stores
and selling coal) formed the National League
of Professional Baseball Clubs.
His Chicago White Stockings – called such
because of the color of their uniforms and
socks – were one of eight charter members,
along with teams from Boston, Cincinnati,
Louisville, New York, Philadelphia, St. Louis
and Hartford.
Play began in April that year with A.G. Spalding
(yes, of ball fame) as player/manager.
Later that year, the White Stockings would
become the first National League champions.
For the next decade and half, the Chicago
White Stockings dominated the league.
They were lead by baseball’s first superstar,
Adrian Anson.
In 1879, he was also named their captain and
manager, forever earning him the nickname
“Cap.”
The team continued to win pennant after pennant
with Anson gaining more and more influence
with the club.
By 1890, he even owned 13% of the Chicago
White Stockings.
That same year, a whole slew of players from
every National League team left the league
to form a more player-friendly one they dubbed,
rather unimaginatively, the “Players League.”
Because of this, Anson was forced to fill
his roster with young, inexperienced players.
So, the newspapers mockingly dubbed them the
“Anson’s Colts.”
It’s important to emphasize here that at
this point in baseball history, team names
weren’t necessarily created by anyone involved
with the team.
They were often, as we would call it, “crowdsourced”
– perhaps a newspaper writer or a fan noticed
a particular trait about the club and would
conceive a nickname based on that.
Unsurprisingly from this, they could be known
by several different names.
As for “Anson’s Colts,” the name got
shortened to simply the Chicago Colts.
Anson continued to manage and play for the
Colts during the 1890s, but his numbers dwindled
slightly from his insane peak, and his arrogance
(like insisting that he play every day despite
being 45 and somewhat past his prime) rubbed
players the wrong way.
His contract finally expired on February 1,
1898 and the team refused to resign him.
Anson was mad, but his great playing career
was finally over.
As a snide joke, local newspapers began calling
the team the Chicago Orphans in that they
lost their “father” Anson.
That name, too, stuck for several years.
They were also sometimes called the “Rainmakers”
because a number of their games were rained
out that year.
The Orphans (though, they were still called
the Colts at times) were not a particularly
memorable team from 1898 to 1901, even though
they did feature a young Frank Chance (of
“Tinkers to Evers to Chance” fame).
In 1901, the upstart American League raided
talent from the National League, leaving Chicago
media to again joke about their ball club’s
nickname.
They now called them the “Remnants.”
By 1902, they were earning a reputation for
filling the holes left by the American League
with young players or, as veterans sometime
called them, “cubs.”
In a Chicago Daily News article published
on March 27, 1902 about the upcoming season,
the writer referred to the team as the “Chicago
Cubs,” with the title of the piece being
“Selee Places His Men – Manager of the
Cubs is in Doubt Only on Two Positions.”
It goes on, “Frank Selee will devote his
strongest efforts on the team work of the
new Cubs this year…”
Now, it was common at this time to call young
baseball players “cubs,” but what made
this a little different was the choice to
capitalize the “C”– making it a proper
noun.
There has been some speculation that this
wasn’t intentional, but perhaps a typesetting
error, given that the article content seems
to refer to the young players on the team
as the “cubs” and not the whole team.
However, the sub-headline of the piece would
seem to refer to the whole team, so perhaps
it was intentional.
Either way, this caught on and for the next
several years, “Cubs” became one of the
accepted names of the team, along with “Colts,”
“Orphans,” “Remnants,” and “Microbes,”
with the latter originally intended as an
insult because of the ongoing dispute between
St. Louis and Chicago about the flow of the
bacteria-filled Chicago River.
However, by 1907, the team was almost universally
referred to as the Chicago Cubs.
chicago-cubsThe next year, in 1908, the team
embraced the name and started taking it literally.
Despite having won the World Series in 1907
and the year previous in 1906 setting a record
of winning 116 games (a mark only matched
in baseball history by the 2001 Seattle Mariners),
they thought it was necessary to have a good
luck charm in the form of a mascot.
(At the time, team mascots were taken very
seriously as genuine good luck charms, rather
than just a marketing move for kids and the
like.)
Thus, they brought aboard a Boston bull terrier
puppy named Bud.
However, fans didn’t take to a dog being
the mascot of a team commonly called the Cubs.
So, the team got a person and put them in
a weird-looking polar bear suit.
Fans liked that a lot more, though history
wasn’t kind to the photos of the team with
the polar bear.
In 1910, the team got a real live cub to be
their mascot.
That didn’t work out so well, however.
At the beginning of the season, they had a
baby black bear shipped from Spokane, Washington
to Chicago.
Predictably, the bear was cranky and liked
to bite the players in the dugout.
So, the team took the bear cub and put him
in the dugout of their hated rivals, the Giants.
Their intentions for the bear were not kind.
Chicago baseball writer Charles Dryden wrote
at the time, “We hope [Giants manager John
McGraw] kicked the stuffing out of the little
beast to get even, for it has been biting
the regular Cubs on the ankle and we have
enough cripples on the team.”
chicago-cub2A few years later, the team brought
in an Alaskan black baby bear named Clara
Maduro.
Despite the cute photos, the Chicago Tribune
reported that the bear was “too strong and
determined in its ways to be among peaceable
people.”
They were forced to send the bear to the Lincoln
Park Zoo.
In 1916, a Montana bear that was on its way
to the stadium to entertain fans escaped its
crate and made its way into a tailoring factory.
It was promptly shot.
But the team was undeterred and got another
bear mascot, named Joa, who lived in a simple
circular cage outside of the Weeghman Park
(later, renamed to Wrigley Field).
As you might imagine from the conditions in
which he lived, he was surely, once clawed
a player and was often seen chewing his steel
chain in an attempt to free himself.
Nearly a century later, the Cubs debuted another
bear mascot – his name was Clark and he
was animated.
The origin story the team concocted was that
the cartoon Clark had heard stories growing
up of his great-grandfather Joa’s exploits
as the Cubs’ mascot and was inspired to
follow in his footsteps…
Of course, had he actually known anything
about Joa’s sad tale he might have run the
other way instead.
Nevertheless, after the team’s World Series
win, Clark the Cub was seen partying with
the team and marching in the celebration parade
with them.